And Fred, as
we understand, this offensive
may indeed in
meaningful ways be underway.
What is the latest there
other, Erin?
Well, there
certainly is a lot going on in the vast
battlefields here in Ukraine.
But the bottom line of things
really is
that the Russians
don't seem
to be gaining any ground anywhere.
While the initiative certainly seems
to be with the Ukrainians,
you have that situation in Belgorod
where the Russians
still have a lot of problems
coming to terms with things there.
Also in
with the Ukrainians
really think
that they're making gains there.
And then in the south of the country,
the Russians are saying
that they're also under pressure
from the Ukrainians.
Here's what we're learning.
Russian military drone video allegedly
showing a massive Ukrainian attack
in the south of the country.
Some vehicles appear
to be hitting mines
or being the target of indirect fire.
The Russians claiming
they're able to hold the line
to the auditory area,
but the enemy launched
an unsuccessful attempt
at a large scale offensive
in the south of Donetsk access.
The spokesman for Russia's defense
ministry said.
But is this already
Ukraine's much anticipated
large scale counter offensive
The Ukrainians claim they have no info.
Kiev put out this video
urging people
to not even talk about
a counter offensive.
Their message plans love silence.
But anti-Putin, Russian
fighters are loudly
making their presence felt
across the border
in Russia's Belgorod region.
The local governor saying
hundreds of munitions
have been fired at towns
there just in the past day.
It's a far cry
from when we were in this area
in February of last year
when Russia invaded Ukraine.
Belgorod was one of the main
staging areas
for the attack on Ukraine's north east
teaming with tanks and armored vehicles.
This military hub seemed invincible.
The streets
that you're seeing up there in the sky,
I don't know how I can see it right now.
You can see more artillery rockets
apparently be firing
from Russian territory
towards the territory.
I would say around half.
I don't know if you can hear this
right now.
Today, Russia's
army appears bizarrely absent.
This Russian military blogger
dodging for cover
in the Shabak in a village
in the Belgorod region.
I just mentioned.
We are lying in Shibuya,
you know, on the ground
under Ukrainian Grad missiles, he says.
Strikes are coming
one after another here.
The local governor
says the shelling from the Ukrainian side
has been relentless,
with several killed and wounded
and thousands evacuated.
The leader of the Varner
private military company
ripping into the defense ministry.
I wish you would hear your name.
We surrender our historical lands,
he says.
Today, children are getting killed.
Civilians are getting killed in Belgorod.
And the Ministry of Defense
is not in a state to do anything at all.
As a de facto doesn't exist.
It is chaos,
and the Russians are also
on the back foot in the area.
Precautions.
Mercenaries just left
Bermuda in east Ukraine.
Moscow's forces
struggling to fend off a strong
Ukrainian military,
both in the occupied
territories and inside Russia.
And, you know,
Aaron, Battle, of course,
is a really interesting place
because the Ukrainians seem to have all
but lost that place.
And now they say that things
are going really well for them.
They also say, quite frankly,
they believe why the Russians
want to talk so much
about the south of the country
and the alleged
advances that the Ukrainians
are trying to make
there is to divert attention
from the fact
the Russians are losing ground
in Bermuda.
There was one spokeswoman
for the Ukrainian military
who said
that today was a very good day
for the Ukrainian army. Erin.
All right.
Thank you very much, Fred, in Kiev.
And I want to go straight
now to retired Army
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling,
the former commanding
general for Europe in the Seventh Army.
So where do you think we are?
General, Ukrainian
Deputy Defense Minister
Hannah Miller
today says it's
not about only about back mount.
The offensive is taking place
in several directions.
So it's present tense.
It's multiple locations.
What are you seeing?
Erin, I got to start off by
first complimenting you
on using the Clausewitz,
the in term fog of war,
because that's where we are right now.
When we're talking today.
We've been talking about mood
for the last several months.
Now we're going to include Volodya
in over Donetsk, Serbian, Inco,
Belgorod, Kursk, Smolensk,
and about 100 other places.
What we're talking about is an offensive
that won't be a massive
beach landing
like we've seen in the movie
Saving Private Ryan,
where tens of thousands of forces
are coming together all at once.
Instead,
it will likely be multiple operations
at different locations
with Ukrainian probing,
confirming or denying Russian weaknesses,
looking for holes and shifting rush of
Russian forces that are shifting around,
taking advantage of Russian confusion
like you just saw on the face
of that young soldier in show Branco.
And it's all going to occur
at the time and place
in the Ukrainian decision.
So what we're talking about right now
is a very different type of offensive.
And we're seeing a building
momentum toward it.
So if you were the commanding general
for Ukraine,
what would you want to see Ukraine do
and actually talk about
this building momentum
and not a Normandy like event,
but what would you
what would you say should happen now?
Well, first would be an honor
to be the commanding general
of the Ukraine forces
because they are doing so well.
But secondly, what I would like to see
is the continued small probing actions
with reconnaissance in force,
taking advantage
of what Ukrainian forces
find on the front lines.
It's not only going to be an issue
of what conventional forces do, Erin.
It's going to be a coordination
between those recon forces,
the operational conventions,
conventional forces,
the territorial,
the so-called National Guard,
the resistance forces
and even the Russian volunteer corps
that are in different oblast
within Russia itself.
The commander of Ukrainian forces
is coordinating all of those things
to cause
the greatest amount of confusion.
And I think
right now
we're seeing indicators of that
because you don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on,
and neither do the Russians.
But I bet your
General Saluzzi knows exactly
what's going on
and he's doing a very good job.
All right.
Thank you very much, General.
I appreciate your time.